please welcome camera so it's good
that's good to hear
this is Aurora this is this is John so
pleased to meet you it's weird getting
older and being on TV shows or pop stars
cuz when I was doing TV shows with pop
stars when I was 18 I would have been
like I want to have sex with you you're
and now I'm 43 I'm like oh your parents
must be so proud to a limit how is it
with you and your ambition you know he's
representing you in the Eurovision song
yeah what is going on there like I know
you tell me it's I mean it's a bit I
mean I don't want to be overly paranoid
but it's a bit dodgy like suspicious
like you've done a song for Sweden but
you've done one for us as well like I'm
working some kind of scam there like
let's take that after the show yes yeah
I'm gonna go straight on social media
yeah do you know what he was saying
about the English entry he was saying it
wasn't just for just the Swedish one
translated it for me
you've been you've been through many of
your books you've been you've been
exploring the world of teenagers yes why
is that so interesting well god I mean a
million things first of all I mean the
key thing for me as a feminist is that
if you look at what you are as a teenage
girl and what your fears are and what
your problems are going from being a
child to being an adult woman whatever
it is that is bad and screwed up about
society and what is bad about sexism and
what is bad about being an adult woman
you can it's all it all happens to you
in your teenage years so whatever our
problems are with bodies with sex with
masturbation with appearance with power
with money whatever it is that we have
problems with adult women doing the
first time you encounter those problems
is when you're a teenager and secondly
teenagers are a beautiful combination of
brilliant noble powerful clever
thoughtful loving generous kids and also
absolute idiots you know I am still very
much in touch with my teenage self and I
was never more stupid yet amazing when I
was a teenager did you how this soft
transition or or the the hard transition
it was a difficult time to be like a
young feminist girl in the 80s because
we only had two role models which was
either Margaret Thatcher or Courtney
Love and I tried to make a personality
and it was two very different story yeah
this is the result
who are you as a teenager and I was kind
of like an old lady
kind of I I was not a teen I kind of
skipped I was just a child and then I
became an old woman I never had any any
I love being home alone with my parents
what do you think that I mean if you see
in 2019 a teenage boy and a teenage girl
what is the difference well it's
difficult because as as a feminist and
an older woman I have been a
professional feminist for 10 years now
and whenever I would guarantee talks
people would be asking questions about
you know advice for women and advice for
teenage girls but then the doors view
one person to go but what I divided
about advice for boys and men and I'd be
like I'm sorry I don't have time like I
am team tits like I am I am all about
the ladies I don't have time for the men
it would be the ultimate irony of
feminism if that women had to sort out
women and then sort out the men like
[Applause]
very very recently but then recently I
started thinking no I think I was wrong
because I think in many ways it is
harder to be a young man now than it is
a woman and the difference is feminism
because if you think about what it was
like to be a woman 120 years ago we were
in corsets we didn't have the vote there
was no such thing as rape within
marriage it was legal to be raped in
your marriage your children will be the
property of your husband you couldn't go
and get a job
you couldn't own property the money was
not yours it was you know terrible now
120 years later you knows things are
still difficult for women but there
isn't a job we don't think we can do you
know kind of you know we have all these
freedoms and I don't and I think we all
think that however difficult things may
be that things will be even better for
our daughters and for our granddaughters
now if you look at men in the last
hundred twenty years what has changed
about being a man like other than the
fact that they don't sort of you know
they don't wear those big tricorn hats
that we used to wear those kind of you
know or top hats I kind of nothing's
really changed to be a man and the
difference is feminism women if feminism
is this structure by which whatever
problem women have we can go out there
talk to each other find advice there's a
you know there's endless books and TV
shows and films that will give you
advice as a woman whatever your problem
is and men don't have that when men have
a problem that kind of where where can
you go what framework do you have what
looks can you reach but this is the
thing though that kind of like you know
when you look at the statistics on
mental health for men like it's the
biggest cause of death for men in our
country under age 50 is suicide yes
which is crazy and like I went on
Twitter a couple months ago and said you
know men we're always asking women what
their problems are but what are the
problems about being a man at the moment
and the replies for months thousands of
them it was picked up as a news story
around the world and some of them were
really sad things they were saying if
I'm out and I see a child that's lost I
feel I can't go and look after that
child because they men are dangerous and
scary I'll have to go and find a woman
and get the woman to come and look after
the child some of them were very silly
those same things like you know
I'd like to be able to dress sexy and
like you know women when they want to
dress sexy they can weigh in a beautiful
bras and pants and silk and stockings
but if you're a man and you want to
dress sexy then all they usually have is
like those little pouches that looks
like an elephant I would 100% go for any
man wearing the elephant pants
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you know what help do men need what are
men's problems where is a place that we
can talk about these things well this is
a place we can talk about it but do you
do you meet a lot of skepticism among
all the feminists when you bring this up
I thought you were gonna say do you meet
a lot of young boys and I was gonna go
no absolutely it's a terrible room at
absolutely yep you know what I don't
because the thing is that like with
feminists like kind of we've either got
sons or our daughters are friends with
boys and you're seeing these young boys
come into the house and you're just like
I think it is in some ways harder
because like you know girls can just go
crush the patriarchy I'm a FEMINIST
what can a boy say you know how can he
identify his problems how can he say
what his gang is unless it's these sort
of old-fashioned ways of being a boy
that you know that are difficult it
means boys can't talk about their
problems so what you're saying is there
is a lot of confusion I think they need
I think we need a male feminism it's
very funny that you mention it is it's
so beautifully to think about and in my
next like in the future I will release a
song which is exactly about this really
that is inspired by and that have you
written that have you got a song it's
called it that's a secret oh really
[Laughter]
it's about this I'm sorry it's so
important yeah you have you you have
teenagers yourself yeah but those are
girls right yes
the easier yeah the easier group do do
they read video books because a lot of
teenagers videos yes I'm very big
amongst teenagers apart from the two
that I gave birth team they if I wanted
to put the most secret information in
the world if I needed to hide it in the
most secret place possible from my
children I would simply put it in the
middle of one of my books and I
understand why because you know my books
are about you know you know my teenage
years you know masturbating for the
first time growing pubic hair having
periods having sex no one wants to read
about their mom doing that no one wants
to know about that every generation has
to pretend that they were the ones that
invented it so I totally understand but
my last book in the front page when you
sort of you dedicate a book to someone
so I dedicated it to my two children I
went to Dora and Evie if you read this
come and tell me and I will give you 100
pounds each
[Laughter]
I mean with having the insight that you
have do you find it easier do you think
that other parents to raise Tina
meanwhile because like all the women
that I hang out with we're all kind of
like you know ever funny feminists and
so we were like well this will be our
power as mothers particularly the
daughters will be funny clever feminists
you know we're getting there whatever
problem they've got we've got the answer
we'll sort this out and I realized after
a couple years that was exactly the
wrong thing to do what you need to be as
a mother is just a you just have to
pretend to be stupid that's what you
really need to do as a mum you need to
because they come to you with the
problem they're complaining about
something and you're like right I'm
gonna get on the phone we're gonna
Google this and I got a phone and credit
card and I'm gonna sort this out and
they get frustrated and angry they don't
like that whereas when they come and
tell you a problem if you just go oh
that sounds really sad that must be
tough what are you gonna do then they
start coming up with answers and that's
when they're happy so you just have to
pretend to be stupid we're gonna have
we're gonna have another guest on in but
I wonder were you talking about
Aurora's production because she writes a
lot of songs and you write a lot of
books and you write columns and you yeah
I mean you you I mean I shouldn't be
here really what's your working routine
how do you work do you have like a
discipline opportunity yes I mean this
might look like it's all just like ah
but really there's there's the mind of a
master scheduling here now is I mean you
do I mean that anybody who is successful
like you work you know you sleep less
than you should you exercise less than
you should but you don't see your
friends as much as you should deter cuz
you just yeah but because there's a
moment where you know when your heart
when it happens yes you'll just like go
now have to be in the moment go now
where are you at your most creative and
yes when it's quiet do you have a place
no it's only connected to silence I
don't like when it's like here it has it
in the background fun which would annoy
me um and I don't like being close to
microwaves either next from the kitchen
yeah and yeah as long as it's quiet so I
just tried to walk into myself for a
long long time and I find that spot what
do you do to get this fire get inspired
I will drink a lot of very cheap coffee
I'm not a person into fancy coffees I
don't have the time I just don't want a
coffee now and I will listen to you
twist and shout by the Beatles every
single time that is such it's like two
and a half minutes of people who want it
like when the beat when they're singing
John Lennon is ripping his throat out it
was like a last take and they want it
and it just reminds you of that thing of
like yeah no I want it I want this job I
want to do my best today done back then
England was really good with pop music
please stop going on about time at the
Eurovision thanks to this gentleman very
kindly decided to give Sweden the worst
song that's what you want me to tell
you're welcome thank you so much for
being here hope you enjoyed the clip for
more interesting conversations please
hit subscribe